willkommen an der militärakademie in
wiener neustadt mein name ist opas
markus reissner ich bin der leiter der
forschungs und entwicklungsabteilung und
heute wollen wir die frage beantworten
warum der einsatz der russischen
bataillons taktischen gruppen der 2014
in der ukraine erfolgreich angewandt
worden ist dieses mal offensichtlich
nicht funktioniert hat und das wollten
wir anhand eines einfachen beispiels
durchführen dazu entführe ich sie mit
dem märz in den raum nordostwärts von
kiew und zwar in den raum von proben
hier auf dieser karte können wir
erkennen den ansatz der 90
panzerdivision russischer seite mit dem
sechsten garde panzer regiment und
dieser ansatz des sechs jahre panzer
regiments in der stärke einer bataillons
taktischen gruppe wurde erfolgreich von
den ukrainischen kräften im raum proben
abgewehrt und wie das vor sich gegangen
ist das werden wir uns jetzt daran sind
kurz noch ein paar worte zur gliederung
in einem video haben wir bereits
dargestellt die optimale gliederungen
der btg was man bereits erkennen kann in
der ukraine ist dass die russische seite
nicht immer über alle kapazitäten
verfügt die normalerweise in dieser
umgebung vorhanden werden ich gebe hier
ein beispiel den ts 1 zum beispiel in
unserem fall wissen wir dass nur ein
einzelnes oder ein zweites fahrzeug
vorhanden waren und nicht eine ganze
batterie an theorie science wie sie hier
in diesen optimalen beispiel dargestellt
das interessante ist auch dass 2014 beim
einmarsch der russischen kräfte in der
separatisten gebieten die ukrainischen
streitkräfte das problem hatten dass sie
versucht haben sie in grenznähe
abzuwehren und dabei von den russischen
kräften umfasst worden sind bzw massiv
mit artillerie bewirkt worden sind
daraus an die ukrainischen kräfte
gelernt und sie haben diesmal die
russischen kräfte herein gelassen und
sich dann erst später bekämpft auf der
anderen seite haben die russen versucht
gerade mit dieser gliederung schmal und
die von schnell vorzustoßen die städte
links und rechts liegen zu lassen um
rasch drehscheiben oder wichtige gelände
punkte einzunehmen und das problem war
dass sie damit konfrontiert worden das
sind dann in die tiefe fallen die
versorgungsrouten angegriffen worden
sind wie nun diese verzögerung kam von
russischer und ukrainischer seite sich
dargestellt hat das sehen wir jetzt an
dieses beispiel sommerregen
ich habe das noch mal hier kurz ins
gelände gelegt wir haben hier zentral
den raum boveri bzw die straße quasi die
richtung nordosten führt die russische
seite ist mit btg schmal und steve mit
einer geschwindigkeit von circa 25 bis
30 km/h aus dem raum nordosten engagiert
der erst die hinterhalt durch der
leichte panzer waffen ist in diesem raum
passiert
die kräfte haben auf diesen hinterhalt
reagiert wir werden es dann kurz sehen
und sind weiter angetreten was dazu
geführt hat dass es noch einen weiteren
hinterhalt diesmal in form eines
verzögerungs kampf durch ukrainische
kampfpanzer gegeben hat und eine
artillerie schlag der schlussendlich
dazu geführt hat dass die btg aus der
organisation heraus gerissen war und
kehrt gemacht hat und versucht hat an
anderer stelle noch einmal anzutreten
beginnen wir mit dem ersten hinterhalt
hier kann man erkennen wie diese
situation war wir sehen also die
russischen kräfte maschine mit relativ
hoher geschwindigkeit heran ohne
infanterie unterstützung und werden hier
flankierend durch den einsatz von
kritischen engler und er begann geschoss
man erkennt zwei abschlüsse
einer dieser abschüsse von dem system
ändert trifft diesen t-72 schwer es wird
dazu dass die besatzung absitzt und der
kraft versucht das fahrzeug weiter
voranzutreiben der rest der kolonie
versucht auf diesen hinterhalt zu
reagieren
das erkennen wir hier einerseits kommt
es zum ausweichen von fahrzeugen in
richtung osten gepaart mit dem feuer der
maschine kann ohne in richtung der
vermuteten hinter halb stelle und wir
sehen dass hier an diesen beiden ämter
bbc pnp wir kennen aber auch hier
bereits das eindrehen der russischen
kampfpanzer mit dem versuch diese
hinterhalt stelle zu bekämpfen das sehen
wir hier das heißt die beiden die 72 die
in der kolonie etwas weiter hinten
geführt worden sind drehen ein und
versuchen mit ihren granaten diesen
bereich wo es hat die ukrainische seite
versucht hat was in den hinterhalt
heraus zu führen entsprechend
anzugreifen
dieser erste hinterhalt führt zu
verzögerungen und die russische kolonie
dreht weiter an in richtung
südwesten auf den marshall an der straße
treffen sie auf zwei ukrainische
kampfpanzer vom typ 64 diese beiden
kampf an so haben den auftrag einen
verzögerungskurs zu führen das heißt sie
beginnen die spitzen der russischen
seite an zu schießen wobei es ebenfalls
zu ausfällen kommt an die 72 dieser
wiederholte widerstand führt dazu dass
die kolonne der btg sich zu
reorganisieren beginnt das heißt man
versucht was in den raum zu verlassen
weil offensichtlich auf seite der
russischen kräfte beurteilt worden ist
dass es hier kein durchkommen gibt wir
sehen also hier eine massive
zusammenballung der kräfte und wir
wissen auch dass bereits zu diesem
zeitpunkt vermutlich der
regimentskommandeur kommen an pt
gefallen ist entweder bereits vorher
durch einen abschluss oder panzer oder
infolge des nun folgenden
artilleriefeuer von ukrainischer seite
auf diese zusammenballung der kräfte wir
können also hier elemente einer bmw
kompanie erkennen hier teile 172 company
hier elemente da biete er 82 kompanie
hier den einzelnen ts 1 privatkino und
zusätzliche elemente die offensichtlich
gerade im feuer der artillerie gegen
dieses artilleriefeuer setzt sich noch
fort wir kennen das hier in einem
weiteren treffer in diesem fall auf
einem pda 82 bisher noch hier sehr gut
die zusammenballung der kräfte und den
beginnenden abmarsch richtung nordosten
was man also hier erkennen kann ist dass
die ptg den angriff nicht weiter
fortsetzt sondern richtung norden mit
seiner kosten ausschließt und sich dort
vermutlich in einer reorganisation neu
organisiert
interessant ist dass wir den funkverkehr
des regiments nach oben kennen und wenn
man sich den funkverkehr ansieht sieht
man das chaos das ist hier geherrscht
hat aus diesen wiederholten angriffen es
war sogar so konfus dass man gedacht hat
von russischer seite dass man auch mit
drohnen vom typ bayraktar angegriffen
wird
wenn wir uns das ergebnis des angriffes
ansehen so sehen wir dass zumindest zwei
die 72 b3 zerstört worden sind 1 beta
82114 durch eine gezielte nadine ripper
hier vermutlich 172 b3 in besitz
genommen dieser hier aber auch zumindest
wo mtp wo wir auf dieses leiter eines
erkennen interessant ist auch die
markierung nämlich für das sechste
gerade panzer regiment die raute mit der
sächsin kern
das interessante ist dass die
ukrainischen streitkräfte ihre erfolge
vor allem darauf zurückführen konnten
dass sie sehr gezielt durch drohnen die
engagieren russischen kräfte aufgeklärt
haben und dann präzisionsmunition
eingesetzt haben politisch
präzisionsmunition wie diese technik ein
produkt das die jüdischen streitkräfte
selbst herstellt betrachtet man die
ausgefallenen russischen panzer so kann
man erkennen dass viele einem massiven
treffer erhalten haben auf dem top
bereich ja wahrscheinlich zurückzuführen
ist auf den einzeln seiner tätigen
präzisions hat die vatikan hatte
zusätzlich für den misserfolg der
russischen streitkräfte und den erfolg
der polnischen streitkräfte ist
sicherlich der bereits erwähnte auswahl
auch das pdg kommandanten des regiments
kommandanten zu sehen der hier in den
ersten minuten des angriffes oder zu
einem späteren zeitpunkt gefallen ist
was dazu geführt hat dass die btg nicht
nur die hinterhalte zu ertragen hatte
sondern auch führungslos geworden ist
damit bin ich am ende des vortrages ich
danke fürs zuhören und auf wiedersehen